[Music]
there is a hispanic holiday on the
horizon
and you know who wants to help you
celebrate la bonita
when it comes to celebrating dia de
muertos la bonita supermarkets they have
all bases covered celeste how are you
i'm great great to have you jc thanks
for being here first off my makeup is so
you guys did a beautiful job with your
makeup what is the history on on the
makeup
so the history on the makeup jc is uh to
basically simplify the day of dia de los
muertos the skull
or the skeleton represents this day so
the more colors you have
the better they're going to recognize
you now so that's
you're always looking beautiful today
you have a special veil on what is the
story on the nail that you're wearing so
i'm actually frida kahlo today
and i am the queen of the day of the
dead so i have a veil and i also have a
beautiful flowers which are also
you know you you're missing the flowers
but it's okay we can i'll let you pass
for two
talking about flowers we have the altar
behind us and these gorgeous flowers the
history of the flowers
and day of the dead so this is the
sempesuchi it is the typical flower of
day of the dead
it's very bright orange and this is on
purpose
it represents the the road that your
loved ones are going to come back
and you know come back to their food and
come back to their drinks it kind of
guides them back so they can get a clear
vision it's kind of like a light for
them
it's the pathway these flowers are
they're just gorgeous let's talk about
the altars that everyone can make at
home
what are some of the things that go into
the altars so on the altar you can
practically put
whatever their favorite items used to be
so for instance right over here we have
a little skull and this one has a little
you know like a little munakita which is
like a little doll
and of course patron you can put their
actual favorite drink in there and
patron we have it on special this
weekend for 35.99
only for this weekend that's perfect now
when it comes to dna mortals you need
the food mr wow come my way my friend
amigo what do we have here all right so
okay so these are our typical food and
drinks for dia de los muertos we have
the famous champurrado
which is kind of like a hot cocoa almost
and we also
you know of course provided here at la
bonita and you
eat it with the panda los muertos with
the los muertos those little bubbles
represent the bones
this is one of my favorite drinks now
this is uh do you guys make this year
round this is a special around
dia de muertos no we make we make it
here in la monita year round and then we
have our famous tamales which are also
on special this weekend for 1999 to
dozen i'm starting with my sweets
everything you can buy everything
pre-made correct yes or you can buy all
the ingredients and make it at home if
you want to
yes and everything that you see here is
at la bonita available for you we don't
want to make it complex for you
it's so good oh my god
oh what a mix you're getting i forgot my
face just made it so good
salty and sweet man also too if someone
really wants to get into the spirit of
the holiday you guys sell like the
makeup
and face paintings as well so it wants
to get done up like me well you know
what we would probably figure it out
yes we will all right you guys dia de
muertos the celebration you get
everything at la bonita we'll send it
back to you guys in the studio i'm going
to keep on eating sounds good
sounds great to me so good oh it's so
good
there are seven la bonita supermarkets
in the vegas valley you can click on
bonitamarkets.com to find the location